you now are mr wonderful you're world
famous abc shark tank i see you smile
when i say it if there's humans on mars
they know who you are uh so this isn't
just like a uh western hemisphere
conversation right it's not just about
the united states and canada i know that
you've got a number of different friends
colleagues and peers all throughout uh
the middle east europe what are they all
saying about this are they jumping in
the game are they still a little bit uh
hesitant what's the international money
doing
it's very very interesting the topic
that's going to be in riyadh next week
is about crypto and there's a tremendous
amount of excitement about it but they
have not pulled the trigger yet they're
trying to get themselves set up for the
moment when the regulator allows it both
in their own geography and in the u.s
you got to remember that those those
funds those those sovereign funds
whether it be in saudi arabia or united
arab emirates a huge amount of that
capital is invested in the s p 500 and
derivatives thereof
huge amounts huge huge amounts so they
cannot be offside with the us regulator
they just can't and so
and i look at this as a huge opportunity
i speak to those guys almost every day
they would immediately go to one to
three percent on bitcoin alone just
bitcoin let alone ethereum or any level
one level twos
on the chain they haven't even thought
about that they're just thinking about
bitcoin and and owning that as an asset
the amount of capital that will come
into this market
when the regulator approves bitcoin as
an asset or currency or a security
whatever they're going to you know
regulate it as is going to be
unbelievable which is why i own it i
mean my premise you know stomaching the
volatility which we all do every
12-month cycle
is the upside is behemoth is huge and so
you know whether it be for me it's an
asset it's a long-term hold the coin i
own the coins the coin i own i don't
trade it i lend it i stake it
and you know i get some income from that
but i'm never going to give up the coin
and you know i heard you guys talking
about the the esg issue i'm sorry that
hasn't gone away but there have been
some new initiatives in raising capital
to solve for it so before we get to the
esg stuff with this international money
right you you talk about them wanting to
go one to three percent just to bitcoin
maybe they would do some other stuff as
well are we talking about just large
family offices in the middle east and
europe are we talking about uh
foundations sovereign wealth funds like
and i'm trying to use that as a proxy
for like how serious uh the most
conservative investors in the world are
about this versus oh this is a large
family office where there's kind of one
decision maker and they're going to end
up making that decision based on how
comfortable they are on a regulation
standpoint and also a return standpoint
yeah um
the the real opportunity is not with the
family offices or hedge funds that
operate on the middle east
the real money is in the actual
sovereign funds
in both saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates
it's billions and billions and billions
of dollars they have not allocated to
crypto yet
when that happens
you'll see it reflected in the price of
bitcoin
there's no question about it and they
have such long-term views in those funds
that and the funds are so large
remember
these countries don't operate the same
way as the west domestic countries do
although they're managed many of the
people managing
those middle eastern funds to sovereign
funds are actually western educated
managers and so they generally abide by
discipline and principles of
you know
risk diversification so they may have a
mandate for example that no stock you
represent more than five percent of the
fund or no sector more than 20
those are diversification mandates that
are used all around the world and they
do that there too
but when you're dealing with a
multi-billion dollar mandate
and some of these are
they're the largest pools of capital in
the world a one percent allocation
is a tremendous amount of money and so
there's a whole bunch of people and me
included heading over in november
um and everybody is talking about not
just bitcoin anymore it's what would a
portfolio look like
if
you know the managers are asking this of
participants that are already building
these portfolios give me an allocation
of positions if i want to be exposed to
bitcoin itself of course but also be
involved in decentralized finance and
also own level 1 and level 2 chains what
does that look like
and i'm heading over i think probably
you and i at some point in the next few
weeks i'm going to give you
my portfolio i'm not finished yet but
it's over 21 positions right now
and i'll i'll do it on your show i'll
disclose what i own i think you're going
to be knocked out but you see what i've
got here because i've gone right down
the radical i've hired multiple people
to do the due diligence on some of these
really eclectic projects but we are
investing